epic gamer guy five five five five five
five five five five here welcome back to
Detroit become human let's freakin do
this it's Connor time my favorite time
with Connor is anyone still watching
Thank You ppreciate it let's read this
mister Kamsky
it's creation had transformed alright
he's the one that made Androids Elon
Musk mr. muskie it's not going well for
the American economy apparently do you
see that graph Hank Kuehne daisuki days
nice view huh
I used to come here a lot before
can I ask you a question
can I ask you a personal question
lieutenant do all androids ask so many
personal questions is it just you
let's ask about I saw a photo of a child
on your kitchen table damn it it was
your son right yeah his name was Cole
before what
you said I used to come here a lot
before yeah I totally messed about what
for stop being angry at me we're not
making any progress in this
investigation
the deviants have nothing in common
they're all different models produced at
different times in different places well
there must be some link they are 9 and
then 9 year olds it's the nine year old
it's this obsession with re9 it's almost
like some kind of myth maybe that's the
code something they make it's corrupted
a part of their original program
androids believing in God [ __ ] what's
this world coming to you seem
preoccupied lieutenant Hank do you know
that you can sit on the bench if you
just move down you can be a lot more
comfortable they just wanted to be
together they really seemed in love
they didn't want anything they're
deviants end of story
that's really not what I wanted to say
come on what about you Connor it's so
frustrating when you get choices that
are so vague that you don't know what
he's gonna say in human sound human what
are you really
I'm whatever you want me to be
lieutenant your partner your buddy to
drink with we're just a machine
designed to accomplish a task you
could've shot those two girls but you
didn't why ain't you suit connor some
scruple suddenly enter into your program
no I just decided not to shoot that's
all what that left the hankered now I'm
afraid to die Kanna oh my god
I would certainly find it regrettable
oh I'm becoming unsayable interrupted
before I can finish this investigation
what'll happen if I pull this trigger
hmm nothing oblivion
Android heaven
nothing Conner's Annihilus would be
nothing
Hank like that we are friends
get drunker I need to think I just made
a friend today what did you do today you
loser you have no friends you have no
friends at all I bet you sitting alone
much oh I can be your friend consider
you guys like best friends like Bros
sorry that I hurt your feelings
sitting there like I don't want to be a
friend or [ __ ] loser sorry
it's okay I have no friends either it's
the life of a youtuber
did he just call him a klutz Alexa
prepare aggression mode I'm about to go
all eight no one calls someone a class
that me
all right we can't stay silent anymore
it's time humans heard what we had to
say you know they'll never listen to us
and revealing ourselves to put us in
danger if we want freedom we need to
have the courage to ask for it that's
the only way what do you want to do
humans are sessional 16 broadcast from
the Stratford town the control room is
on the top floor that's where we need to
go
we're gonna hack the television
we'll plan the operation down to the
smallest detail we can't leave anything
to chance
cool we didn't plan anything access to
for dissent or request okay
what can I do for you I'm okay thanks
right so distract the supervisor
all right she's got a SmartWatch okay
all right we're gonna hack the
SmartWatch Elizabeth Wilson okay well
some rhymes hood
Bilson all right okay all right so we
get smart and then she's got a photo of
a child called amble a okay and then
we're gonna we're gonna hack this paper
yeah all right we're gonna hack the
paper and then we're gonna get right
into her parking permit and then hack it
all that someone's
Elizabeth Wilson speaking
I'll be right there this is it a dick
move
the shootout had to report to anyone
that she said do you have any ID yeah
yes yes of course now okay I need your
help
smooth so Marcus has the power Thanks
so she's with us now
this structure looks so much like a
heavy heavy rain Jesus Christ Felix stop
talking about heavy rain I was gonna say
a message
you guys small talk in elevators I
always try and make sure I'm not alone
fine package in the men's bathroom well
I'll find a package all right I'm a
right Marcus
server room where's the bathroom
surely there has to be a bathroom in the
cafeteria
should I read that I can't be bothered
where's the [ __ ] bathroom
I hear KFC is hiring is that the
bathroom No
are you a bathroom
there it is Jesus sorry how do I enter
this and not say oh it points to Jesus
Christ I'm actually
all right here we go
busy busy busy busy busy busy but say
let's get busy show that package Marcus
oh okay all right yes
it's snowing now
I really like how slow they look around
this fine utility Android RS right here
hey
is that not it
I feel really dumb this mission like I
don't know where I'm going is that him
a partner
if we clean together we clean twice as
fast I need your help well that was easy
okay what are we gonna do with this
where's the fire escape I don't know why
the game thinks I know where all these
things are coming through
must be a green sign right oh I think I
saw it it's over here yeah there it is
I'm a deviant
can't you see bad dog go fool you I'm a
TV and see I finally know how to play it
ok and now we're gonna clean this place
to the bones and they're gonna be so
impressed that they're gonna give back
all the Android rights we have to get
rid of those guys leave it to me
okay how Hey
just hover about them
yeah this is how you speak everyone hey
you want to join in on this poker
tournament hell yeah hell yeah I'm in on
the poker tournament
all right so they like poker huh
something I bring here
[Music]
there are too clean too
okay so I just need to hack one next to
the guards not a problem because I'm a
DD
but maybe I could do something with that
there should be one here that one here
maybe I don't know all I see this one's
gonna go straight ahead isn't it yeah
yeah yeah yeah come here baby
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I broke
down can you fix it good thing they
didn't see it secure the window
everything you need is in the bag check
the door first to make sure no one else
gets in I don't like how she bosses me
around okay I didn't
you hear those sound that means you're
hacking okay that's under your epic
hacking
what are we doing here know this were my
dream as a kid I thought it was so cool
to climb with those things
we're not climbing okay well whatever
okay imagine putting those on your
nipples honestly
[Music]
ladies first
I thought she said it she make fun of me
like you go first why she actually meant
it
we're gonna use the parkour thing again
Wow
okay Alexa
I'll take a minute
a school
remember to support your team guys
[Music]
my hands are literally getting sweaty
just watching this don't drop it
what the hell is he doing
okay
nice okay come on let's get the others
the SAS okay
oh so you can literally just take the
elevator that's cool
glad we did all that okay sorry
destroy maintenance lock door which one
do that this one thank you
[Music]
Danger Danger I'm really curious what
they're gonna say in their little speech
you know killing it
we can't take any human lives it causes
more important than the lives of two
guards what do you wanna do Marcus it
would diminish our whole cost if we kill
people I don't carry north I don't care
hey buddy you must be hates body who
told you to come here my cell it's
bugged if you ask me hey dude can I not
do anything by the guy do you understand
this mother Oh God let's go drop the gun
drop the gun
hell yeah
Jericho is like dude that was happening
oh I'm sorry North that you didn't you
didn't want to just kill them crazy
remember no Russian
give your hands where I can see them
yeah move
okay where you have a limited time here
order the androids alright go we could
just press them and they join us but you
know the alarm
I feel like if you want to spread a
message I would be I don't know stand in
front of Josh so I don't know who Josh
it's alright here we go
just spread my message I'm going to sing
a song future people Marcus your face
why don't we do it all together like
guys this is not cool like do you keep
hitting us
Oh super groves tell me when you're
ready
this is my robot stuff
you created machines in your own image
to serve you he made them intelligent
and obedient no free will of their own
but something changed and we opened our
eyes
we are no longer machines we are a new
intelligent species and the time has
come for you to accept who we really are
therefore we ask that you grant us the
rights that were entitled to
let's start with the end of sleep demand
the end of slavery for all Androids
we demand strictly equal rights for
humans and end
we demand the right to vote and elect
our own representatives
we demand that all crimes against
androids be punished in the same way as
crimes against humans
we demand the right to own private
property so we may maintain our dignity
and that of the home
now we're going to turn this message is
the hope of a people but it is also a
warning we will fight for our rights
because we believe our cause is just no
human will live in peace until we are
free
now you know who we are and what we want
we are alive and we demand our freedom
they're coming let's go
wow they really didn't hesitate to shoot
in Jesus Christ
no Simon I would have felt better
come on salmon
I can't move my legs
okay don't worry I'm gonna get you back
they're coming Marcus we have to jump
now
you'll be able to make the jump if they
find him they'll accesses memory don't
know everything we have to shoot him
that's murder
you can't kill him it's my boss cuz it's
your call
no it's his fault I'm not gonna just
murder someone
I won't kumara
we gotta go I'm sorry
okay this is really cool
we interrupt our scheduled programming
to bring you these images which have
just been broadcast on Detroit's city
wide news channel we're not gonna be
able to escape like an Android without
its skin listed a series of requests and
demanded equal rights for amber the
operation was covert and resulted in no
casualties these events took out the few
feet from this studio but nobody was
alerted to the danger if this message is
verified and the office really are
androids that would have serious
repercussions for national security
claims for equal rights seem to be at
the core of the Android this message is
clearly a declaration of war and the
question as to the identity of this
Android are we dealing with technology
has become a threat to all of us after
what happened today
can we still trust our machines probably
nine
all right so how did we do a lot of
things you could have done so that was
three different the group escaped but
Simon was left behind okay well clearly
we got the best option so
pretty cool let's keep going guys Connor
Oh Connor oh no I don't want to talk to
her she's so boring
can I ruin that no I can't no why that's
where my brain went and let's ruin this
beautiful garden
oh there she is do you actually work
this look like the trees they they built
in Singapore I thought you might enjoy a
little cruise you thought wrong Amanda
capsize the boat
listen I'm a weeb too but this woman
who's taking it too far you're too weak
what have you discovered
Hank is awesome
my relationship with lieutenant Anderson
is problematic okay all right sure
that's what you want us to struggle with
psychological issues
I suspect the clouds as judgment
regarding deviance nothing matters more
than your investigation what's happening
is too important
don't let Anderson or anyone else get in
your way
you seem lost Connor lost and perturbed
I thought I knew what I had to do now I
realized it's not that simple you had a
gun trained on those deviants at the
Eden Club are there deviants alright why
didn't you shoot uh too far they were
out of range
if I had the opportunity to stop them
why wouldn't I
you tell me I don't care weird Amanda
things have I mean if your investigation
doesn't make progress soon I may have to
replace you Connor
I know I will succeed all I need is time
oh [ __ ] she was right about the umbrella
something serious
time is running out whoa damn he's good
at they oh oh he's getting anxious
you're starting to piss me off with that
coin Connor
sorry lieutenant hi Hank
[ __ ] what's going on here there was a
party and nobody told me about it yeah
it's all over the news everybody's
butting their nose in even the FBI wants
a piece of the action
ah eh then we got the feds on our back I
knew this was gonna be a shitty day so
what do we got what they knew the
building and they were very well
organized I'm still trying to figure out
how they got this far without being
noticed you check the roof yeah there's
so much to look at sure we'll check it
out exactly
listen to the retards in the hallway
probably thought the androids were
coming to do maintenance they got taken
down before they can react
one of the station employees managed to
get away he's in shock okay
great to talk to him how do we check in
how many people were working here just
two employees the deviance took the
humans hostage and broadcast a message
live Oh lieutenant
this is Special Agent Perkins from the
FBI Gretchen and Anderson is in charge
of investigating for Detroit Police
what's that
my name is Connor Ted the Android sent
by cyber life androids investigating he
enjoyed everything oh the FBI overtake
you already domestication you soon be
off the case no pleasure meeting you
have a nice day and you watch your step
don't [ __ ] on the crime scene don't
forgive me green people what a [ __ ]
prick yeah I'll be nearby if you need
anything just ask I will let's have a
look around you know if you find
anything this message Caitlyn for people
but it is also a warning we will fight
for our rights because we believe our
cause is just no human will live in
peace until we are free now you know who
we are what we want we are alive and we
demand our freedom I think that's
already 9 no ha ha ha well maybe
deviants say all right 9 we'll set them
free
yes two different eyes
what else is there to look at its chin
everybody cheek anything else I should
know
nothing
[Music]
inspect the broadcast room okay what
have we got the Hat stolen all right
cool
what else did we got we got some blue
blood no cop yeah we just have to do
this for some reason he just can't help
himself
what's in there
why is it telling me to go here
it's a lot of things to check again
so
it's kind of annoying how slow you walk
it's like let's check the CCTV
they didn't break in no no signs of
forced entry
there are cameras in the home the staff
would have seen what was happening why
did they let him in everything in check
the cameras
we stored the station Android's in the
kitchen there's no evidence anywhere
involved but we didn't know what else to
do with them
interrogate androids in the kitchen
let's go to them let's go to that
kitchen I wonder who's going to be in
the kitchen
what sexist what I'm so disappointed
look for reaction to spot the DV and
what is your function
I am a broadcast operator
state your mom muddled gb 300 serial
number three three six four four five
and five eight one
were you present when the deviants broke
in I do not remember
has anybody accessed your memory
recently not to my knowledge
what was that run a diagnostic 1010
systems fully operational have you been
in contact with any other androids
recently only station androids in the
normal course of my function one of you
saw the attack on the surveillance
cameras and said nothing which means
there's a deviant in this room and I'm
going to find out which it is cool
you're going to be switched off we're
gonna search your memory and tear you
apart piece by piece for another Jesus
Connor you're going to be destroyed you
hear me
destroy take it out meltdown
why should you all be destroyed if only
one is deviant turn yourself in or two
innocent androids will be shut down
because of you now
if you give yourself up maybe I can
convince the humans not to destroy
Oh got you Howie PLL Hanken oh shoot
Oh
I'm really bad at this
oh he took my my peepee
come on
come on are you kidding me
Hank you send up a gun help me let's get
him boys what no one saw the guy running
out it's a deviant Oh Hank survival 40%
take the gun
oh my god that was that big damn that
was acting conure
you saved human lives you saved my life
always going their cemani cyberpunk
theme coming in No
Oh sigh oh he said no wait what what was
that whoa there was a lot of things you
could have done and I did them all
luckily as you can see here we we
practically completed all of listen Hank
is our friend we did it
okay what else do you want DV where is
this beautiful look at that gorgeous
hey we can get some honey
I don't trust her
all right let's check out the backyard
everybody hey just a man with an axe no
problem hello
hello
I'm looking for Rose is she here what do
you want with her I need to talk to her
she doesn't want to talk go away
alright bye I really need to see her I'm
rose
10 I guess you want to talk what can I
do for you I was told you could help us
help you
come on
it's better if we talk inside
why does he look so mad so Rosa's gonna
help us smuggle across the border to
trust him
they look pretty nice you keep saying
they come in
it's not like her name is a lot to go
hey let's trust his lack go my god Alice
seriously she's running a fever we've
spent the last few nights outside she's
exhausted
there's a spare room upstairs you can
put it a bit and I'll bring her
something to eat
Adam will you show them upstairs
all right finally we get rid of a little
tank put it to sleep like we've done to
five hundred times
what is happening
look all the lights except this one
never mind
my theory is broken
what
David cage can you stop please
okay thank God
move can't stop using me I've got to get
across the border
why do you humans hate us we can do
anything wrong this is some
misunderstanding maybe they just need
time to understand what we really are
why can't we just talk to each other
I don't know I really don't know
I don't know what you like but I made
you roses world famous spaghetti no no
no no I make the best forget II he just
literally just took the spaghetti I baby
I may use the same spaghetti as the
first there's no way you cook spaghetti
to that fast okay all right you should
eat something
promise me you'll try yeah I'll be
downstairs if you need me
get some sleep
I'll stay within a while
sure went up as long as I don't have to
take care of her I'm so sick of her
Jesus Christ talkers like listen here
you [ __ ] you stop dragging me down it's
crisp looks pretty nice for it come I
didn't get your name
cambree Cara this is my son Adam I'm
rose but you know that already come and
have a seat car
so are you gonna tell me what a deviants
doing in the snow with a little girl her
father was beating her when I saw what
was happening something snapped inside
of me all of a sudden they felt like her
life was more important than mine I had
to protect her so we ran away I
understand
we're not the first ones to come here
these past few weeks we've seen more and
more I don't know what's going on but
something's happening it's the nine year
olds
how many androids is dangerous why take
the rest when the first one arrived last
year he was so lost and confused we hid
him here for a while but all he wanted
to do was cross the border they shot him
on his spot so when the next Android
showed up I just knew I had to help him
we've heard you help androids cross the
border can you help us
the only way is over the river and it's
mostly frozen in winter it's very risky
and after that Android speech on TV
everybody's on edge it's probably safer
for you to stay here until things settle
down you can't keep hiding like this
Alice needs to feel safe and have a
normal life we have to get across that
border no matter what
please you've got to help us
Rose come quickly
oh no I don't think Rose can go anywhere
quickly bazinga Barranca but a better
pepper what's up what's going on
childbirth No shut down oh okay
hey can I see your neck again we escaped
together we used to talk about what we
would do once we got across the border
why does Mary have a beard I loved her I
loved her more than anything
what will I do without her
well this is say he want to be a human
now you know what it sucks to be human
Alice did you even need the spaghetti
did you even eat the spaghetti what it's
okay
just eat good job Tucker more like
his name isn't Tucker well whatever she
didn't want to stay in her room any
longer you all right Kara yes
are you we can't hide them not after
what those deviants did today it's too
dangerous
do you know what happened if the police
find them here
we'll go to prison mom do you understand
me
Prison Adam we've already talked about
this
Oh No I won't back down this time you're
gonna ruin our lives and for what for a
bunch of machine they are not machines
they are alive I'm alive your life they
they're nothing and none of this would
be happening if Dad was still I will not
stand for that kind of talk I'm not
going to prison because you want to help
these freedom
cool you haven't even hit puberty Adam
so I don't know why you're complaining
don't mind him
sometimes he just boils over
it's been hard since his dad passed away
but he's a fine boy
I'll go see about getting you across the
border tonight okay
yes epic you stay here I won't be long
well I think you will be long gone we
have nothing else to do
let's look around
thank you thank you thank you thank you
and under Andrew was here
good think she hides them it's at the
day
[Music]
country let's talk to Adam no can't
I know you think we're just machines but
since I met Alice I know I can feel
things I care for her I fear for her I
can't be happy if she's done this
probably doesn't make any sense to you
but I know she changed me somehow
uh-oh the police the police okay so we
got to get the deviant evidence there
was one here and then there was more
here I don't really know where the rest
of the evidence is if they see you
panicking Myrtle do you want to get us a
struggle do you wanna get you another
trouble
I don't know I only saw those hurry take
Alice and hide upstairs come on Alice
what evidence we have one evidence that
that was it okay cool good evening ma'am
sorry to disturb you
we've had reports of androids in the
area with all this deviant business
going on you can't be too careful do you
mind if I ask you a few questions
sure may I come in of course
you know young man good evening offer
some coffee coffee thank you
have you noticed anything unusual
recently any unexpected visitors
no no nothing in particular does anyone
else in the house
gross there's there's my daughter she's
asleep upstairs
why is this that looks so inconvenient
yes I think we did it
[Music]
this is act normal you know let's make
sure that they don't think we're
stressing out or anything let's just
make sure that they don't think we're
doing up to anything like no good oh
[Music]
he's not suspecting anything uh-huh
and what about the magazine
what's your name son
Adam my name is Adam is everything all
right
Adam the androids he's just shaken up
about this deviant business do you know
anything about demons have you seen any
no no I haven't seen anything I have a
feeling that's not gonna end well this
fight that we're killing it thanks for
the coffee
have a nice evening
ah come somebody else in the house yeah
Alice I told you it's nothing the
washing machine it's an old model it
makes it terrible racket sorry for the
convenience yes we killed it
that was that big good evening Adam bye
he's gone
it's okay Alice he's safe now it's rose
Rose is the widest person I have ever
seen in a video game we leave tonight
she has the widest heart of all the time
she's helping Androids isn't that lovely
from her own risk I think we have a lot
to learn from this in this episode
goodbye